bill in arizona let's say good morning
to him
hey now can you hear me
hey now hello hello hello
testing one two testing
testing hello hello
hello hello hello hello hello
hello bill hello hello
hey now hello hello hello
hello hello hello
bill are you there in arizona hello hi
hello hello hello
hello hello hello
hello
[Laughter]
hello hello hey phil from
phil from arizona yeah hi bill
hi hello hello hello
hello mr stern how you doing hi mr stern
how you doing it's bill from arizona
hello
yes it is hello hello am i
hi am i on it's bill from arizona hello
hello hello
hi it's bill from arizona hello
hello this is it this is bill
bill from arizona still from arizona
hi hello
hello bill from arizona you're on the
air hello how are you doing
good how are you doing it's still from
arizona hi
hi phil hi no it's bill not phil
oh hi bill hi how are you i'm in tucson
yeah is this bill from arizona
yes this is the hello hello
hello bill from arkansas hello you hear
me
i can hear you i hear you
i thought we were getting a call from
tucson where am i
coming from five people on the phone at
once
no it's just me bill from arizona yeah
hello hi now we have bill from barcelona
on the air hello bill from
barcelona yeah yes
hi
hi bill where are you from arizona from
barcelona
hello mr stern this is bill from arizona
the original caller
mr cern from arizona the original caller
i'm the original arizona
[Laughter]
i think i got caught in multiple
universes there must have been a bunch
of lines that converged but all from
people named bill
you know what i think it is i think it's
you tan mom you get on and everyone gets
confused
hi who is
you